die Kölner Justiz die zuletzt lacht fast
ein halbes Jahr lang tanzte Bandidos
Aykut Ödem Behörden auf der Nase herum
und löste sich zwischenzeitlich sogar in
Luft auf bis jetzt wir fassen in das
Versteckspiel des Rockers noch mal
zusammen
jetzt ist vorbei mit der übeltäterei der
Rüppel Rocker I could Öl ist gefasst
nach 5 Monaten Flucht geschnappt Flucht
geschnappt Spiel und das obwohl du dich
lieber Aykut doch immer für den
schlaueren gehalten hast aber alles auf
Anfang im Juni 2020 wird Aykut Ö Boss
der Bandidos festgenommen der Grund eine
Schießerei mit den befeindeten Hells
Angels in der Nähe des Kölner Doms aber
der Protz Rocker hat Glück wegen
unerlaubten Führens einer Schusswaffe
wird er nur zu zweieinhalb Jahren
Haftstrafe verurteilt und das sogar auch
noch im offenen Vollzug die Haft tritt
der 33-Jährige aber nie an erst musste
eickhut angeblich sein Haus in der
Türkei verkaufen dann hatte er Corona
und am Ende zwickte auch noch der Rücken
ein Hexenschuss Arme eickhut der
Staatsanwaltschaft wird das zu Recht zu
bunt und die Erlass deshalb Haftbefehl
doch in Köln war eikut gar nicht mehr
der rübel-rocker einfach abgetaucht
spurlos knapp zwei Monate später wird er
aber in der spanischen Urlaubsstadt
Marbella dingfest gemacht und das bei
einem abendlichen Spaziergang an der
Promenade tja Pech gehabt ausgerockt
nach zwei monatiger Flucht ist der
Kölner Rocker eickhut in Marbella
festgenommen worden eickhards Antwort
die ließ nicht lange auf sich warten
[Musik]
ist noch lange nicht ausgerockt
Öl hält die Justiz und uns von Bild zum
Narren wie konnte das passieren die
spanische Polizei ließ ihn mit einer
elektronischen Fußfessel und
Meldepflicht wieder frei wieder
verschwindet Aykut und wieder führte die
Behörden an der Nase herum und dann vor
zwei Wochen der Durchbruch
bei einer Großrazzia geht Eiko den
Behörden zufällig als Beifang ins Netz
die Beamten finden 11,5 Tonnen
11,5 Tonnen weißes Gold auf einem
naja großen Schiffscontainer und nein es
ist kein Mehl dass die Polizei dort
gefunden hat die Spur führt zu seinem
belgischen rockerkollegen und Bandidos
Chef Gerd friesund der zufällig auch in
Marbella wohnt und raten Sie mal wer
sein Nachbar ist hmm genau deutsche und
belgische Spezialeinheiten stürmen die
Wohnanlagen und bringen den Rüpel Rocker
in die JVA Remscheid es hat sich
tatsächlich ausgerockt mit dem trotz ist
es jetzt erstmal vorbei vielleicht
darfst du lieber Icod aber wenigstens
deine lilafarbene Couch mit in die neue
Zelle nehmen tja wer zuletzt lacht der
lacht halt immer noch am besten
tja und zugeschaltet sehr sehr
bildschirmreporter Frank Schneider
Franke das klingt wie eine Posse ist es
aber nicht
naja was heißt es ist keine Posse es ist
folgendes gewesen er hat es halt einfach
clever angestellt er hatte die Justiz
genannt nicht nur in Deutschland auch
später in Spanien erstmal muss man ja
mal sagen die Strafe dir bekommen hat
extrem milde man konnte ihm eben keine
Tötungsabsicht unterstellen man konnte
auch nicht ausschließen hat in Notwehr
gehandelt bei dieser Auseinandersetzung
mit den Hells Angels und hat er nur 200
Jahre bekommen wegen unerlaubten
Waffenbesitzes und er hat auch sogar auf
einen Vollzug bekommen man könnte ja
eigentlich denken der muss wirklich drei
Purzelbäume schlagen das ist so
glimpflich davon gekommen aber er hat
dann entschlossen ich will auch nicht in
den offenen Vollzug ich will auch nicht
nachts in der Zelle schlafen und hat
dann eben immer Dinge vorgeschoben wir
haben es eben im Beitrag gehört jetzt
was angeblich ein Haus verkauft dann was
Corona dann was ein Hexenschuss aber die
Atteste fehlt und dann haben die
Behörden irgendwann gesagt uns reicht's
wir beantragen ein Haftbefehl das hat er
natürlich mitbekommen und ist dann
abgetaucht noch mal mehr da gab es ein
internationalen Haftbefehl der wurde
auch dort vollstreckt nach zwei Monaten
dann hieß es aber er darf gegen
melderauflage und eine Fußfessel wieder
auf freien Fuß und die deutschen
Behörden sollen ihn abholen als die dann
kommen wollten war erneut abge braucht
und dann kam es eben zu dieser großen
Razzia und da hat er das große Pech dass
er in der Nachbarwohnung wohnte des dort
Beschuldigten belgischen Rockers und die
Polizei hat natürlich das Objekt ob
serviert vor dem Zugriff und haben dann
gesehen oh wer geht denn da ein und aus
in dieses Haus wer wohnt denn da auch
noch den suchen wir doch auch ja und so
kam es zum Zugriff und jetzt ist er
überführt worden vor zwei Tagen und
sitzt in der JVA Remscheid mit offenem
Vollzug ist es jetzt jedenfalls erstmal
vorbei also es hört sich alles erst nach
so zufallstreffern an wie du schon
beschrieben hast warum glänzt die
Polizei da so gar nicht
naja was heißt die Polizei glänzt nicht
erstmal ist es ja so dass der
Haftantritt der hat die Polizei nichts
mehr zu tun der Haftantritt der hat ja
auch keiner mitgerechnet bei 200 Jahren
offenen Vollzug ist es jetzt nicht
unbedingt eine Strafe wofür man abtaucht
und sozusagen größeren ärgereskiert und
die spanischen Bürger haben auch gesagt
na ja das ist halt unerlaubter
Waffenbesitz das ist jetzt nicht so ein
schwerwiegendes Delikt und es sind nur
200 ja auch noch Vollzug dafür sperren
wir den jetzt hier nicht länger ein
außerdem hat er auch beteuert er lebt
dort mit seiner Familie mit seinen drei
Kindern seiner Frau und er will einfach
nur an seinem Haus bei seiner Familie
sein und er stellt sich den deutschen
Behörden und das hat aber eben nicht
gemacht und daraus hat man jetzt gelernt
deshalb wie gesagt sitze jetzt eben
nicht mehr im offenen sondern
geschlossenen Vollzug und wird seine
zweieinhalb Jahre wahrscheinlich dann
auch wirklich bis zum letzten Tag
verbüßen müssen er war Chef der Bandidos
in Köln ist Köln jetzt ein Stück
sicherer
naja ein Stück weit sicherlich schon es
ist immer die Frage es wachsen ja in
diesen Strukturen auch immer wieder
Leute nach manchmal ist es auch so dass
solche Festnahmen oder Verhaftungen auch
eher zu Auseinandersetzungen führen weil
er entsteht ein Vakuum in der Szene
andere wollen da reindrängen andere
wollen Führungspositionen andere wollen
mehr Geld verdienen und dann gibt es
auch zusätzlichen Ärger Nummer muss ich
ja noch mal vergegenwärtigen 2019 gab es
in Köln auf den Ring ein regelrechten
Rockerkrieg der damalige
Polizeipräsident auch jetzt noch
Polizeipräsident Uwe Jakob sagte damals
in einer Pressekonferenz das sei wie im
Wilden Westen da würde mit hochkarätigen
Waffen herum geschossen und das ließe
die Polizei nicht zu die Polizei das
auch massiv verstärkt hat auch massive
Einsätze gefahren die Situation hat sich
auch wirklich deutlich beruhigt
insgesamt hat sich die Rockerszene ein
wenig beruhigt sie haben das
kundenverbot sie können sich nicht mehr
martialisch zeigen aber in Köln brodelt
ist immer man muss wissen in Köln die
Ringe waren lange in der Hand von den
Hells Angels dann wurden sie schwächer
und dann drängten eben eickhut mit
seinen Bandidos dort hinein dass er
jetzt sitzt kann sein dass es erstmal
Ruhe bringt in die Szene die Straßen
etwas sicherer macht aber diese
Schießereien die wir vor zwei Jahren
noch erlebt haben sind zum Glück in der
jüngsten Vergangenheit ausgeblieben wir
hatten allerdings einen Fall innerhalb
der Hells Angels wo möglicherweise auch
als ein strafauftrag auf einen Rocker
geschossen wurde er wurde zum Glück
verfehlt ist jetzt in punther
Polizeischutz und in der Szene brodelt
ist immer es geht um sehr viel Geld es
geht gar nicht mehr um dieses Rocker da
sein wie früher die haben alle gar keine
Motorräder teilweise gar keine
Führerscheine für Motorräder sondern es
geht einfach darum unter diesem
Deckmantel des rocker-daseins kriminelle
Geschäfte zu führen und möglichst viele
illegale Gewinne zu machen